a that it's misogynist the meaning of
all women
but offensive as it might be should such
misogyny be a hate crime after all
anybody who assaults you or harasses you
will face a tougher punishment if you're
black or disabled or transgender and the
judge believes that fact motivated their
crime
but if you're a woman
even if your assailant tells you to your
face that it's because you're female it
will make no difference to his sentence
some campaigners say that killings like
that of sarah everard are fueled by
misogynistic attitudes encouraged by
non-violent acts verbal or social media
hostility
they want a new law to put sex and
gender on the same footing as race and
disability
but the government's official advisers
the law commission say that a new law
could create more problems than its
souls for example making the prosecution
of domestic abuse even harder than it is
now
our choice should misogyny be a hate
crime or is the call for a new law just
virtue signaling
in the next 60 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight are the conservative
peer and former victims commissioner for
england and wales baroness helen knew
love she led efforts in the house of
lords to make misogyny a hate crime
and ella willen journalist and author of
what women want fun freedom and an end
to feminism
okay let's start if i may
with you helen christian names here um
why do we need a new law
we need a new law in a sense of the
research as former victims commissioner
meeting many female victims felt that as
a woman they were absolutely demeaned
and it didn't fall part of an
aggravating factor in domestic abuse
sexual abuse
and having listened to um there's other
people who have been involved with
stella crazy mp i think it's the part
woman has been absolutely missed in
uh high-end domestic abuse and sexual
abuse crimes so when we say an
aggravating factor we don't mean a
separate crime but if you're assaulted
or harassed in any way you
are liable to get more years or bigger
fine or whatever it is because of that
specific factor that it is against a
person of a particular kind i think it's
important to put that in as an
aggravating factor and and and to be
making people aware i did work with the
judges within the house of lords as well
because the government were relying on
the law commission report that was just
a standard default um answer to any
questions raised but working with a lot
of women who have suffered and feel in
fear of their lives um actually it was
important that they recognize that yes
you may be a jewish woman and they've
attacked you for anti-semitism
or a muslim woman they've attacked you
because you're a muslim but actually
they've also attacked them for
being a woman as well and that is being
missed and has an effect that actually
we're not breaking the cycle and it's
actually looking at the perpetrator
instead of putting all the owners back
on the victim all right before we go on
to the meat of it um
why are you so interested in this
personally there are a lot of other
kinds of victims that you dealt with
yeah i think i think a is a mother of
three daughters and also somebody who
has been through the criminal justice
system
uh i worked beforehand in the courts and
then being on the other side so to speak
i felt this this is after your after i
lost my husband gary in 2007.
i think it's very interesting to see how
the dynamics shift all the time and as
yes victims commissioner for all victims
of crime but majority that i saw with
with uh domestic abuse and rape victims
and sexual abuse victims they felt very
unsafe they felt that actually by
reporting a crime which i met quite a
few victims who went to report crime of
rape and it was very much dismissed you
know you're not the only woman loved
tonight that you're going to be raped
which in itself is appalling but the
fact is they felt that because they were
a woman okay
uh ella wieland
what harm can it do to give law
enforcement uh officers an extra tool
well i mean spin that question say what
i'm gonna do to give law enforcement
officers uh more work to do or
expand their remit of how far they can
delve into um individuals private lives
i think that's what i'm more concerned
with
there's a you know when you when you
introduce um the my book there's it
tells you a lot about you know you kind
of smirked at the subheading which a lot
of people do they're kind of all into
feminism what does that mean and i think
that part of the delight we're having i
just think it's a rather daring thing to
say yeah that's why i put it as the
subheading but it's it's it i think it
signals a lot that um you know the
discussion about in particular things
like misogyny hate crime or
whether or not you know you should be a
feminist today is kind of a given it's
like if you don't agree with this you're
either uh you know going along with
internalized misogyny you think that
violence against women isn't that big a
problem and there's all these kind of
assumptions that are made in actual fact
i think that this kind of law change
represents a real harm to women's
freedom and it's a bit of a tricky thing
to explain but i think that the in the
last sort of 20 and 30 years
contemporary feminism has moved away
from an argument for women's freedom
independence
ability to risk and enjoy public life in
the same way to the same extent that men
do and we've moved more towards a focus
on safety at the sacrifice of freedom
and i think that in particular something
like hate crime really represents that
where you would be inviting um police
officers to have greater remit into
looking into women's private lives you
know being able to question people who
say something nicely to a woman online
be able to keep personal details on
files and to really act as a kind of the
insinuations that women need police
officers to act as almost like a
watchful older brother in order for us
to move about our lives i think that
that i think one it insults women's um
independence intelligence um authority
and agency but also i don't think it
does anything to uh address the real
questions in society that we have to
answer about women's status women's
position women's
the remaining sexism in society that's
that's a okay that's a broad outline
just
i wonder if you could as uh i asked
baroness
why is it that you feel so strongly
about this particular law because you
write about all sorts of things actually
some of which are to do with identity
some of which to do with other issues
well one of the reasons i wanted to
write the book and look into it further
is because it's a bit it can be
irritating when people ask that question
because i think women always feel
beholden to say well as a victim of
something like this or because i've
suffered this level of abuse whatever
and yeah i you know meet a woman who
hasn't had a bad word said to them by a
man most women have but i'm not i i've
always been um more interested rather
than the kind of you know personal
anecdote to look at what is the future
of the status of women in this society
and there is so much that has to be done
whether it's in relation to child care
provision abortion i'm sure we'll get
into all of that all the rest of it i
want to push forward for a future of
women's freedom and leave behind this
rather patronizing idea that we're sort
of fainting
all right fainting maidens in need of a
knight yeah i don't think i don't think
there's any fainting maidens in this
studio but let me just get one thing
clear i mentioned the mail on sunday
story do you both agree that
the story itself or the way it's
presented
falls under the banner of misogyny
i just thought it was gutter pressed to
be perfectly honest i just think it was
very demeaning to both angela you know
angela reyna as a woman and as an mp in
in a house of commons um angela can
quite
vocally stick up for herself as a
northern woman but i just thought that's
the lowest of the low and politically i
don't think it did the government any
any
goodness in a sense of why would you do
that that's you know but it is about
it's highlighting misogyny but again
like ella just said you know we don't
need a knight in shining armor certainly
angela doesn't know but it did knock did
knock angela as well um and so for me
that you know it was an appalling story
to put out there about a political world
that's already you know hard for women
do you agree i agree it was completely
crass and sexist and i think it's more
embarrassing for the tories because no
one is not going to be on angela's side
and i think i don't think anyone took it
seriously either but but but also i'd
like to add to that the desire to kind
of then extrapolate from you know one
article in one paper on the basis of
unnamed sources yeah to then extrapolate
from that to suggest that there is a
problem with misogyny more broadly in
society or indeed that this now with the
suggestion that the speaker has to get
involved with ticking off a paper as
speaker of the house i think that tells
you something about the do i even want
to use the word yeah i do the panic
around misogyny hatred of women it's
very serious thing that it's sort of
just everywhere that it that this
piece by this one individual represents
a generalized hatred for women either in
the houses of parliament or indeed and
wider society i don't agree with that
all right let's first
look at the the case um that you've made
helen for this change um and
some of the objections first of all that
actually the law commission's basic
proposition which is that it wouldn't be
practical that rather like um
some other pieces of legislation forced
marriages to that and so it frankly
wouldn't
be used very much because it's very hard
to prove the standard of proof would be
standard of evidence would be extremely
high and it would take police effort
away from uh more serious more immediate
crimes
my answer to that is police are under
resourced anyway we don't see police
officers so let's put this in in context
at the sense of all this because the law
commission report
it felt that they weren't looking for a
solution they were finding a default
button to actually not solve the issue
my point is and from my background i've
seen too many women demean and these
aren't women who are faint i'm very much
for the suffragettes and the power and i
think you know what ella said about
child care about how women perceived are
absolutely you know it's not right as a
mother of three daughters i can tell you
they're very vocal uh in what they're
doing but the whole point is is that the
law commission really didn't answer what
we wanted them to answer and for me what
was missing in our criminal justice
system is aggravating factors if we put
that to one side you can get a case
where they're charged with murder and
they've raped their victim but that rate
won't follow through because the murder
is the higher the end of the two where
actually victims families want them
charged with the murder so with the rape
sorry so i think it's about the
aggravating factor it's understanding
what that that woman's gone through and
i'm you know to say we don't police
they're already under resource doing
that the fact that sue fish from
nottingham was actually doing looking at
you know she was the chief he was the
chief of police at the time i think it's
really important that i think it's for
me when i started this amendment and
this conversation it's opened a lot of
can of worms as well and i think there's
a lot of dynamics we need to add to this
for people on the ground to fully
understand what we mean by it
i think it is important to fully
understand what is meant by it and
actually i mean you made a great speech
defending your amendment and at the time
but one of the things that you said in
that was that this wasn't just about
collect you know things that i think
generally most people would accept are
do no harm collecting data finding out
how much of this stuff is happening you
know who could argue with that but you
made the point that this was about
sending a message that this kind that
the law would be used to send a social
message to say that this isn't
acceptable now i as someone who
generally opposes uh a government
overreach into people's private lives
and actually i'm opposed to hate crime
in general because i think it's slightly
ludicrous to suggest that either you can
police emotions through hate um i'm not
entirely convinced that a slap in the
gob hurts more if someone's hitting me
because i'm a woman or because i'm five
for a or whatever um so but that aside i
think this suggestion that
you that people have to rely on the law
to change social norms is completely the
wrong way around if you look at the way
in which women have got in you know
where we are in 2022 um over the last
few decades it's not been through
with the greatest respect people in the
house of lords or politicians
instituting laws and the rest of us
saying oh what a good idea it's been
through grassroots movements of you know
feminist campaigns women campaigns of
arguing our position in society and it's
a bit of a tricky point to make but i
think that today and it's a and it's one
that people kind of find too
controversial to take on but i think
it's true
i think we have to have more of a sense
of women and men being able to stand up
individually and you know in public
against this kind of bad behavior rather
than relying on legislation to fix the
problem for you because things like you
know
murder rape indecent exposure assault
domestic violence all of these things
are illegal already i want to come back
to this point about resilience um
in a moment after the break when we talk
about your case but um helen the heart
of what ellen just said actually
is refers to something that you said i
think in your speech in the house of
lords where you said
misogyny
violence hatred abuse and entitlement
that some hold in their hearts towards
women
can you really legislate against what
somebody has
in their heart i think hate is a
behavior it's from you know and the
behavior attitudes ways they treat the
women so i think it follows through
that's why it's a night it's got to be
an aggravated
you can't legislate hate the word but i
think it's behaviors that follow through
their actions that you can legislate
okay what about the um the issue of the
practicality of this because uh it's
been raised again and again that
actually
it sounds
it sounds right but for example
uh that there's a sort of spread ella
said that she's worried about hate crime
in general but for example
we now have in london adverts that say
don't stare should staring at somebody
on a train be potentially illegal
well i've not seen them adverts in
london and i've not seen them in the
north
i'd be all over the cheap right so
ignore i know my ignorance in that sense
no i think there has to be context to
this i think the context is if you know
at the end of the day somebody's staring
it depends if that person is constantly
on the tube and doing that it puts you
in fear i think there should be
discussions but i don't think even
police officers will come out for just
staring i just think i think sometimes
we have to have a proper conversation
about this
and from working with victims and
listening to the criminal justice system
i think it is a big gap about
understanding what women go through and
that is why they've got no confidence to
go forward in in maybe going to the
police reporting it but most importantly
i personally i don't think there should
be prosecution for somebody staring at
you that's a common sense ground but you
see the problem here that some people
would say that uh the point about
misogyny is that it is if it is a
feeling it's not an act and that you end
up with a wide spectrum which might for
example start to criminalize flirtation
and
i don't suppose anybody wants to do that
do they
but i think sometimes women feel if
there's somebody being flirtatious to
you they do feel very intimidated
because they're weak and they're not
because they can't stick up for
themselves but actually a situation and
i know personally from losing my husband
within seconds can get very volatile can
get very violent so i think at the end
of the day i think it depends when you
say these words it depends on the
actions and the behavior of that
individual towards that person that
feels in fear for themselves which is
why the problem with the law is that
it's a blunt instrument and indeed the
you know the
if you look at for example there was
this recent um poll done of by from a
teachers union um back in april where it
found that 70 of teachers reported that
they had suffered some form of misogyny
you think oh terrible headline what's
going on in schools you then read down
the report and find out that one of one
of the things that teachers are
reporting um are that children uh make
sexist comments about women at home and
they say that feminism is a terrible
thing now that's that might be a
political position you disagree with but
certainly not hatred of women and i
think there is a real blurring of the
lines about what um misogyny constitutes
and indeed these kind of important gray
areas in between people's relationships
between men and women you know whereas
you know no i completely agree with you
i'm glad you say that you don't think um
staring would be criminalized but if
someone suggested that they you know
that they're being stared at as a form
of sexual harassment then you can quite
clearly see how reporting that to the
police could result in a hate in a hate
crime report and that's a problem
because if you're being stared at by
some lecture you don't want to be scared
out that's a problem if you're being
stared up by someone you fancy it's
completely different you know these are
the gray areas in society that matter
all right stay with us uh we're going to
be testing the ground a bit further but
it already looks like um
we're beginning at least to have some
agreement that have to be that there's
some limits here but we can't still have
to see what the gray areas are and what
is white and what is black back in a
moment
[Music]
[Music]
the 60th anniversary is a critical
milestone for us it's a moment of
reflection
looking at who we have been how we have
been and where we are going so for us
it's it's a matter of
glorying in our culture
the
things that have made us who we are and
the this confluence of cultures and
ethnicity that has woven itself into the
jamaican mosaic uh and all four fathers
saw it well by having a motto out of
many one people that's who jamaica
really is out of many one people and we
want to glory in that diversity and to
show the world
that our rich culture and uh our diverse
offerings uh represent a little piece of
them we are a small island state
but the largest in the english-speaking
caribbean characterized by very strong
biodiversity lush green vegetation warm
climate we have a
temperate climate running through the
entire year
we have a wonderful waterfalls and
stalagmites and stalactites
and food jamaica is known for its
cuisine
excellent food delicious and electable
jamaican cuisine
[Music]
organization
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground
i'm joined by conservative peer and
former victims commissioner for england
and wales baroness helen nulov and the
journalist and author ella willem we're
talking about whether misogyny should be
made a hate crime um
ella
why shouldn't women have the same kind
of protection against prejudice that
people of color or lgbt people
well i mean i think it's a convincing
argument to you know that why are women
left out and i could um i don't want to
we could make our head spin by bringing
in the whole discussion about the fact
that lots of politicians at the moment
can't decide what a woman actually is
let's not go we'll go there but you know
so i understand the the argument for
wanting to include it in um hate crime
legislation but i would um actually say
instead of adding to the list why don't
we look at and question why we need or
want to have hate crime legislation
if it's just about collecting data then
i'm sure there are other ways we can do
that without adding to the statute books
and adding to legislation um let's be
innovative here but actually i don't
think it's about that i think it's about
a general trend to want to try to as you
said look into people's hearts try to
police thought and police how we speak
to each other police what we think about
each other and police politics when we
see this happening
most uh pointedly on social media you
know there have been i mean to take the
trans example there have been several
instances of people being individuals
being arrested for things that they've
said on social media that's that delves
into a critical realm of uh you know
being critical of gender ideology for
example so we we know that this isn't
just a kind of uh uh nicely nice let's
just figure out the data and get the
world better for
minorities this is about trying to
influence public opinion on certain uh
political positions in relation to
religion in relation to race whatever it
is i think that's a real problem you
cannot police hate and also i don't
think we should this is a kind of funny
point but i don't think we should be so
um single-minded about the emotion of
hate because indeed if you make you know
obviously hatred is is not a a good
thing and and uh in the abstract but
people hate
their living conditions they hate the
politicians they're represented by they
hate the world they live and they want
to change things your hate has been a
driving revolutionary force um
throughout history in a way and so i
just i get very itchy about the idea
that we would want to police and
demonize hate in this kind of particular
way that's true all of that is true but
we're speaking now about
the piece of law
that helen knew love introduced which
was to make hate cr uh misogyny um
anti-woman
sentiment if you let's put it that way
an aggregate aggravating factor in
crimes like violence or harassment and
so on
do you not accept that part of the law
is to express
desirable social norms you know we have
laws about levels of noise we have laws
about what you
what parts of your body you can expose
and not expose in public why shouldn't
there be laws that basically guide us to
where
uh
what what what sort of uh violence we
think is particularly heinous or
unacceptable because it's associated
with um
with feelings toward a particular group
of people bear in mind this isn't you
know we're not we're talking about
crimes that might not be
that are usually not necessarily against
somebody that you know they're just
against
a person because of what they are
there's not something they can do about
anything about you i mean there's there
is this i mean to really badly
paraphrase i think it was jermaine grier
who made this point there is this sort
of
you know odd
suggestion that
violence against women in particular
rape is somehow a much worse crime than
other forms of
violence i think we need to interrogate
that idea that um you know there is so
much um
not kind of not that the focus is a
wrong thing but that there is so much
prioritization of that that you would
have to have a hate crime to inform a
societal view of violence against women
as opposed to two guys beating each
other up or something else and i think
that pop i mean just part of the you
know let's be clear here um i'm not
trying to equate the two because there
is we do have come out of uh
sexist societies you know history tells
us that women have been denigrated where
men haven't um over the decades and
centuries and so two men beating each
other up is not the same as a man
beating up a woman it has different
historical uh meaning and it's loaded
differently but i just don't uh i don't
perhaps it's my my politics
and my sense of democracy and that i
don't think that law should instruct
the plebs i think that people and public
inform social norms but i think as
somebody who's seen a level of violence
that i did and my daughters have seen i
think the impact of the emotion of
violence is where we need to protect
women
because at the end of the day where we
can you know religion
and you know sex and everything else but
that the fact that a woman has been
demeaning eyes been brutally attacked um
through hate um and has actually we've
now got more children through domestic
abuse families who see the woman as the
lower class in the family
i do think we need to be common sense
about this i don't it's not about
creating more laws it's actually
understanding that that impact has not
been has not had an effect on the
sentence it's more to do with their
religion their colour and um and for me
as somebody who's seen a level of
violence and i've seen so many victims
who feel demeaned feel that people don't
understand because the women oh that's
okay and everything i feel that we're
stepping backwards in a sense of that
we're not supporting this piece of
legislation to make sure women are in
the aggravating factor for the common
justice now that's the far end because
not everybody goes to court we're seeing
that the lowest rates for conviction for
charging for rape victims but i think as
a society i think we've become so pc
people are scared of doing anything or
reacting anything when i lost gary
people were scared of going out to the
streets it's not that simple and i just
think
in essence when i've listened to this i
think it's so important that we have a
common sense approach to this and it's
not just about the law it's about people
having faith to come forward and have
that opening ear from a police officer i
think it's a really important point that
um you know you characterize it as us
being more pc and i think that we're
certainly more nervous about each other
more nervous in the way we talk to each
other partly because there has been a
real drive for censorship in politics to
suggest that there are just some things
you can't say and that that section of
the things you can't say expands i'll
say to my 19 year old you know she comes
out with where's massive mom you can't
say things like that she said i'm 90.
what are you going to do put me on the
naughty step but i think that i think
that bringing in this kind of
legislation or indeed any kind of
regulatory measures you know not just
law but policies in workplaces um you
know policies and universities that have
kind of speech codes or things like that
only drives a further wedge between
citizens ability to interact with each
other because the public life is only
healthy when it has a rough and tumbler
to and fro and if we i get to a
situation in which you know particularly
in relationships between men and women
heterosexual relationships and
interactions um there is always this
barrier of the police officer or this
threat of legis of legislative action i
think that's just going to make people
more nervous and less willing to have
that you know it's going to make women
less willing to say hang on a minute
what you just said is wrong and bad and
don't say it and i think that's a much
more natural way of changing people's
minds all right
i i want to stick with this point but
we're going to go to break um we've
heard what some of what our guests think
and why um next we're going to try to
begin the search for common ground
though i think we are getting towards
something like a common understanding
there's a couple of things to sort out
first see in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground i'm
joined by conservative peer and former
victims commissioner for england and
wales baroness helen newlove and the
journalist and author ella whelan and
we're talking about whether misogyny
should be made a hate crime
we've found out some what our guests
think um and we're now going to try to
see if we can move towards
some kind of common ground or possibly
not what we get there ella
let me ask you about this the
many people who support the idea of
misogyny as a hate crime
make the point that
the extreme end
of violence
against women choice of control and so
on is not entirely separate from what
might seem like small
issues which
you said
we need to build up people's resilience
against but is do you not accept that
there is a case for what in the context
they might call the broken winter's
windows strategy here you need to deal
with the small things because if you
don't deal with those small things they
create an
environment in which the big crimes the
horrible crimes
uh take place with more frequency
well i think two things can be true at
the same time the first is that
quite obviously the reason why there are
there you know men commit violence
against women in the numbers that they
do uh in particular you know levels of
domestic violence it has a
direct relationship to women standing in
society it's about you know historically
the way in which women were positioned
you know particularly in a domestic
violence setting which is about keeping
a woman under control at home in
horrible coercive fashion
you know to suggest that that has
nothing to do with politics of um
women's history or women standing in
society that would be ludicrous the
thing that is simultaneously true is
that it will also be ridiculous to
suggest that which i think happens far
too often from some of my feminist
comrades is that just because an
individual
wolf whistles says crass things maybe
pushes it too far on a common um or even
you know goes as far as groping or
things like that that that will
automatic that that leads in this
sliding scale as it's put towards things
like um rape and violence and very
serious crimes now you know obviously
there are instant you know we know that
with um the individual wayne cousins in
the case of sarah everard there was an
individual who did move through a
sliding scale of behavior from indecent
exposure and watching violent
pornography right up to committing rape
and murder i think we just need to
preach caution when we try and suggest
that bringing in punitive measures for
what we've talked about as the gray
areas of society how people interact
would solve the problem of rape and
sexual assault and
violence and murder because i just don't
think that's the case and more
importantly really quickly i think that
what that what criminalizing and
panicking about those lower end of the
behavior scale things does is freak
women out it causes fear among women in
fact in um in nottinghamshire there was
the report proved that the introduction
of hate crime made loads more women feel
like looking over their shoulder and
nervous which i'm not comfortable with
but isn't that that's a fair point but
isn't that that perception is that's
down to communication it wasn't to make
people feel to make people have
confidence to know that actually they
can report and be believed and i think
like you say the sliding scale with
wayne cousins it shows again that he was
allowed the movement as a police officer
and the culture of how women are treated
and as i say you know i'm i'm quite a
guppy northerner and and i've read
things where you said you know you're
quite you've been brought up tough and
everything but there is also occasions
where actually enough is enough and
women can be very vulnerable you know if
we have problems still in this country
we're stalking you know and it if the
sliding scale leads to more serious
violent crimes with a loss of life and
we have this reactiveness in this
country to do something after the horses
bolted and instead this this misogyny
the amendment i wanted was to ensure
that it's enshrined in an aggravating
factor and we would break the cycle and
actually put the onus on the perpetrator
or the guy or what other woman you know
this misandry this misogyny is actually
saying this is not the correct behavior
and as an example in in the schools that
you gave me 70 with what sexism and
everything i think you know this is
where we've become to pc in a sense we
can't have a common ground conversation
because people are very nervous because
it's going into areas that actually
could be called racist you know about no
muslim people anything like that it's
become very toxic we've created it and i
i am in the political world but i might
pee is about people and understanding
and i do not like the wind addressing
which i feel sarah everard's case became
winder dressing for politics and
actually the people who were who wanted
something when you say
impressive politics what do you mean i
mean that the headlines sound fun
before but what you're not meaning what
you say on the tin which is how i came
into as a campaigner for victims and
what i went through for family for my
family
um you know i've had many conversations
with previous prime ministers but the
fact is that you can lose sight i you
know i'm a conservative peer um but at
the end of the day surely we are all
here to do the best for the public we
saw that with the pandemic we all used
to clap for the nurses and whatever but
i don't know i think the the society's
become very toxic haters become very at
the top you know people are really angry
and now we've got the poverty line
everything's been spewed into it so i
think there is an issue about hate per
se it's about behavior and i think we
need to tackle perpetrators just stop
that cycle
on this point i want to talk about
where you might meet uh i guess in the
middle but just on this point about the
if you like the social norms ella um
there is i don't want to go sociology
lecture or on you but there is a a
theory
which is evidenced that if you can make
a group of people
seem a bit less
human than everybody else
uh by
by creating a stereotype for example
that you know women are just passive and
so on then it is easier
to do horrid things to them and this is
not about an individual but it's about
the society overall do you not buy that
at all i do buy that actually and i
think that part of the problem with this
kind of legislation is it's it is really
buying into the idea that women are more
passive and more in need of um
protection and you know i you know i
often say the same thing you're saying
goblin north and i'm a gobbies londoner
and uh but you know the flip side of
that is you can it's you know a woman
could come along and say well i'm a very
shy person i'd never speak up and
there's nothing wrong with that
shouldn't be you know that should that's
there's you know that's not anything to
criticize but on an individual basis but
on a political basis i think we need to
start getting serious about saying that
women are just as rough and tough and
able as men and able to deal with
adversity in in society that faces them
now that's not a popular opinion because
that means me telling women right no
you're not going to should shouldn't
confront someone when they stop you at
three o'clock in the morning in an alley
i'm not an idiot um and i don't want
women to get her but in those low level
uh end of the scale the things we've
been talking about whether it's you know
sexist comments or things like that i
think we do have to get more serious
about having a grassroots response to
this which is women pulling on the
hobnail boots and set you know
metaphorically and or perhaps not and
giving men who need it a kick in the
backside but you know politically and
physically by saying then that's how you
change the perception of women as
passive and weak and in protection
do you accept that there's there's an
element of this in that picking out
women
in a way suggests that women need
looking after
no i think that's the wrong con i i
respect what ella said in a sense you
know i i as i say i'm a mother with
three daughters and i've got friends who
can actually say this this is about
understanding there is a percentage of
women who are who are continuously being
harassed by men who are continuously um
have actions by men and can lead to
serious violence because she was a woman
this isn't about saying we're going
backwards and we're women are weak no
they're not but there's a percentage of
women and within our criminal justice
system take the politics out of this
that's why i don't do the wind
addressing is to say that actually
they've got no confidence to go to the
agencies that should be there to protect
them
by all means you know i give them the
confidence to do but don't demean them
as soon as they set foot to say i feel
that i'm you know hate crime or i've
been attacked because actually you're
going to miss a percentage of women who
are being actually harassed with violent
men and domestic abuse and sexual abuse
who then feel that actually well i'm
going to be we're already saying going
to be weak all right let me let me
we have to move on to think about what
we could do yeah let me just take a
couple of minutes to ask you both about
a couple of uh possibilities
i mean one thing we could sim we could
do is what law commission has suggested
don't change the the big laws it were
but extend the law which currently
exists on race and religion
uh against stirring up hatred language
stirs up hatred extend that
uh to sex and gender why not just do
that as a start okay
well i see i don't think that covers a
lot i think that's how do you then
actually
persuade the rule of law to say actually
you were stirring up hatred uh because
again it's about hatred and it's about
an emotion it's about behavior so it is
in there and it may actually come to
that victim who is a woman there is men
you know there is men here we can't
dismiss that but majority are women of
this crime so i mean that seems to be a
bit like you're not really standing
you're sitting on the fence you're not
actually saying standing up because it's
too difficult to solve i just really
oppose any law that suggests that in
particular that speech should be policed
i mean i don't think it's an accident
that this amendment has come within the
police bill which is an incredibly a
liberal punitive um terrible a piece of
legislation that's exactly the bill it's
yeah it cracks down on all kinds of
freedoms let's not go there but i mean
it should be shot down in every case but
the the fact that they're you know this
isn't about let's just get real here
this is not about the conservative party
thinking how can we make nice life for
women this is about the conservative
party moving with a trend to police
behavior and thoughts and that's not
where i come in i'm on about people i've
met on the ground i'm about people women
who feel very that they're not being
believed and i've got people who are in
violent offend uh relationships who have
no confidence to go forward and the only
way we can do that he's making this
aggravating factor all right trevor's
attempt to find a way through here
number one failed number two uh ella
it's not just a conservative party the
scottish national party led by a woman
yes yeah wants to bring in
the the
idea the law that misogyny would be a
hate crime
why not let's put it this way let's see
what happens in scotland
think about scotland as a pilot why not
well i mean scotland as a pilot is a
terrifying fact the snp on various other
pieces of legislation relating to
freedom of speech are heinous let's be
clear on that they you know want to um
engage in the policing of citizens
behavior from what they think to what
they say online offline and i think that
is it's not just me sounding off about
my pet peeve which is censorship it's
actually relevant to this which is that
you know particularly in scotland there
is this
within the s p let's be clear there is
this desire to control how citizens
interact with each other that is not how
a democracy should be moving this isn't
about controlling and i totally agree i
think we should have freedom of speech
this is about behavior but this wouldn't
give freedom of speech no it's kind of
no it wouldn't but it would help the
people that actually are suffering i
agree with this tough women out there
and i agree we're not weak but actually
i think we have a common ground where
actually i want to make sure people who
need this law are protected but i don't
want actually police powers to it to
stop freedom of speech all right uh i of
course have to make the point that uh
the snp are not here to explain or
defend their point of view that will be
for another program we're going to go to
break now
but uh we've heard really
pretty thorough going discussion from
our guests and they've heard from each
other in a moment i'm going to ask them
if the either them sees any prospect for
common ground based on what they've
heard
and i'll give you my view stay with us
[Music]
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek so we'll be
discussing the biggest stories of the
week so far talking about what's still
to come having a look at prime
minister's questions of course and
getting reaction from politicians plus
our very own viewers and we'll have
analysis from my sky news colleagues the
take with sophie ridge on sky news
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland
the very issue that's been the source of
tension here for generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy
essentially
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
[Music]
is
organized
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground i'm
joined by conservative peer and former
victims commissioner for england and
wales baroness helen nulov and the
journalist and author ella whelan we've
been talking about whether misogyny
should be made a hate crime uh we're
coming to the end now so i'm going to
give each of you a minute to
tell me what you feel you might have
learned from our discussion
and if anything you've heard has
actually changed your mind helen
that's been a very interesting
discussion and i take on board some of
the comments that ella said however i
still haven't changed my mind i think
it's not about blocking freedom of
speech i think it's about protecting
those women um and those victims and not
actually having something happen to them
where we have another big outcry
and somebody's lost their life so to me
i do think we need to close this gap and
to make people safe and that they can
report it
ella
well i'm a stubborn mule i'm not going
to change my mind when it comes to
women's freedom because i think that
some of the greatest threats to women's
autonomy today are from a knee-jerk
patronizing style of contemporary
feminism that has sacrificed women's
freedom for safety
and i want that to change but you know
i'm with 100 helen on the
um the seriousness of some of the stuff
that women face whether it's in relation
to in particular in relation to domestic
violence which i think you know does not
get enough of a hearing and some of the
people on my side like to play down the
issue of sexism society say you know
we've moved on there's nothing to talk
about the most definitely is something
to talk about so i'm with you there but
i think that the way we talk about it is
not to institute um punitive legislation
but to have a grassroots bottom-up
reigniting of women's power um call me
old school but i'm more inspired by the
movements in the 60s and 70s of women
putting up their fists metaphorically
and physically to sexism than i am by
either amendment introduced in the lords
or legislation that seeks to treat women
i think a lot of the time like children
well look thank you both very much um
i've learned quite a lot in this uh
i think what we can definitely agree is
that both of you regard this and the
treatment of women as a serious issue
there's nobody in this discussion who
doesn't think that there is a particular
question to be answered uh i think that
if there's a
beginning difference it may not be about
the issue of misogyny itself but more
about whether legislation can do
anything to tackle the problem that you
both agree ella is obviously less
persuaded
about that you helen are more so and i'm
a little bit uneasy about the
sense that you think that you can build
resilience i think that the challenges
for some women are much greater than
than
i in my view than one might imagine
helen i wonder if whether
actually you have too much faith in in
legislation one thing we didn't talk
about is whether there should be more
resources for tackling this and i
suspect that both of you might agree
that uh that we do need that
um but i think what you both agree about
is that we do need to talk about this
issue and we talk about it openly and
some aspects of it
are particularly tricky because they
involve both
uh assessments of men and indeed some
groups of men and some cultures within
our communities and so on
so we'll probably return to this we
haven't got kumbaya today i don't think
we've got a cut we've got common ground
but actually what we've got
interestingly i think is two quite
different views of modern feminism and
that i think
has given me an idea for a further
addition of common ground
but uh to you who've been watching thank
you very much for joining us tonight
we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
organic
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is sky news at 10
live from dinipro in eastern ukraine our
top story
the russian onslaught in ukraine south
and east sky news reports from two
cities under constant bombardment
well again
this place has come under attack
they've managed to get everybody out of
the village
but we need to leave now too
putin's revenge russia cuts off gas
supplies to poland and bulgaria as
tensions grow between moscow and the
west
also coming up on the programme missing
presumed dead detectives investigating
the disappearance of katy kenyon arrest
a man on suspicion of murder
plus a double whammy for renters as
monthly payments rise so too to the
threats of eviction
without any prior notice uh
notes of eviction came through the door
and i was literally it
i was in a state of shock
a